our robin walker the school's minister
who joins us now live
mr walker thank you very much for being
with us and good morning to you so just
tell us what is the british government
doing to try and make sure that these
men are released
well i mean as the foreign secretary has
made clear we will offer all support we
can to them and their families we have
been absolutely clear throughout that
these people should be treated as
prisoners of war under the geneva
convention there is no basis on which
they can be put on trial this is an
illegal court in a sham government that
has held this trial and obviously we
don't recognize it has any authority but
we will continue to use all diplomatic
channels uh to make the case for these
are prisoners of war who should be
treated accordingly
i mean diplomatic channels is one thing
is there any more assistance being given
to these men of course remembering that
they are in a breakaway separatist
region
we will provide all assistance to their
families and it's right that the foreign
secretary has spoken out about doing
that um clearly they are in this area
controlled by russia's proxies
and that's why it's absolutely vital
that russia recognizes its obligations
under international law and meets its
commitments under the geneva convention
will the russian ambassador to the uk be
spoken to today
um i don't have that detail but i know
that my the foreign secretary has been
clear but we utterly condemn the
approach has been taken here and we will
use
every method at our disposal to uh take
this issue up so i think that's really a
question for my colleagues at the
foreign office okay uh thank you for
that mr walker let's talk now if we can
about um something that's affecting
everyone here in the uk of course the
cost of of living crisis we've seen that
uh more record high prices for fuel
what's the government doing to try and
make sure that people can actually fill
their tanks
affordably
well first of all we saw in the recent
spending review the 5p cut to fuel due
to it was the biggest cut in in many
years but i recognize that's been more
than outweighed by the pressure on the
wholesale cost of energy that's why we
have to help people directly we have to
make sure that the kind of support
through the 37 billion pound package
that the chancellor has announced going
getting money directly to people through
their energy bills through council tax
through changes to universal credit
through the direct support that we've
announced can make a difference and will
make a difference but this is an
enormous challenge and i recognize i
have constituents who are profoundly
affected by the cost of energy i've
always campaigned both as a backbencher
and a minister to try and keep fuel duty
uh down to to to reduce the impact of
that and i think the chancellor will
continue to have to look at all the
tools at his disposal uh to try and keep
these costs down because of course it is
the case that when fuel duty all fuel
prices rise substantially it has a
broader impact on the cost of living
it certainly does i mean the one thing
that could be done right now is to
reduce fuel duty again couldn't it
well i think that's obviously a question
for the treasury i i i i
there's always a strong case for looking
at whatever we can do to help on these
things um but but let's say the most
recent fiscal event we had the biggest
cut in fuel duty that's ever been
delivered um by a government that is a
substantial move
and and
and of course you know i think it's
right that we're looking to help people
in other ways 37 billion pounds is a
very substantial package of support it
does mean that uh some of the poorest
families in society will be getting up
to uh 1200 pounds uh to to to help that
is a substantial difference and we've
got to continue to look to see where we
can put our arms around people and make
that kind of difference
now there's some reporting this morning
that people who work in health and
social care teachers as well are finding
it impossible to fill their tanks and
get to work because of the cost of fuel
what should be done to try and help
those people who work in the public
sector
well clearly where people are
recompensed for their travel that needs
to be looked at though those figures
need to be looked at to make sure that
they're keeping pace um with the prices
um but also we need to make sure um that
we are you know making sure that people
actually do have keep more of the money
that they earn and that's why i think
the rising of the threshold in national
insurance is really important that will
keep more money uh in people's pockets
uh it's why the whole range of measures
the 37 billion pound package of support
that the chancellor has announced can
make a real difference to keeping people
going uh supporting people but it's also
why and i think the government has been
clear about this we need to keep all of
these things under review to see if more
help is needed
when will that help be coming though
because we we do keep hearing that more
help may well be needed and things are
under review we've seen some measures
come in but as you'll know that those
measures have been criticized as not
being enough
well i think we we have uh you know had
a range of measures some of which have
already come in 150 pound uh council tax
rebate increases in the household
support fund and the the increase in the
the national living wage and the cut
field gc they're already in place uh the
next step will be the increase in
national insurance thresholds which will
make more money uh to what people uh can
can keep from their pay packets uh and
then eight million households on mean
tested benefits will be directly sent
the first installment of their 650 pound
cost of living payment um so these
things are rolling in um over time i i
think they all make a difference i think
we also need as and i i think michael
gove was clear about this yesterday to
make sure that we are holding the
retailers for account but they are
passing on uh the cuts to fuel duty that
the government has uh delivered uh and i
think there's more that can be done to
to to ensure that that's happening uh
and and you know i i'm very keen that we
continue uh to support people on the
basis of of disadvantaged people on
disability payments pensioners people we
need to make sure that we get the right
support out there as swiftly as possible
and of course for my responsibility in
the school space we're also continuing
to invest in the holiday activities from
food fund making sure that children have
more support not just during term time
through free school meals and the people
premium but also outside of turn time in
a way that no ever no government
previously ever has
uh mr walker you'll know there's a price
tracker uh in play uh being used in
northern ireland at the moment to keep
an eye on petrol prices that's something
you'd want to see more widely used
across the country
uh i haven't seen the detail of that and
it's not it's outside my brief so i'm
not gonna comment too directly but i
would say as a local mp i used to
publish a table of the prices of the
petrol bumps in my constituency i can
see the value of doing that and drawing
people's attention uh to where prices
are cheapest and whether there's any
outliers who aren't passing on the
prices i do think it's important that we
do everything we can to help the public
so we ought to look at whatever's being
done uh in other parts of the uk to see
if that works
okay uh mr walker let's have a little
discussion about stuff that is within
your remit of course and i want to play
you quickly before we talk about what
you're here to talk about today um
something that the
social uh mobility czar told our beth
rigby last night about the prime
minister so i've listened to this
no i do not think so
um
i don't uh
i wish he could be but he isn't um and
that is a bit sad i like boris i don't
think he's a bad guy you know um but i
don't
i don't know enough about what he's got
up to but i do not think that he's a
good role model for children
apologies for setting you up like that
mr walker that question was put to uh
miss burble sing is boris johnson a good
role model you heard her answer he's not
well that's her opinion of course she's
entitled to her opinion on that i think
actually anyone who leads this country
is a role model someone that children
can look up to the prime minister has
shown phenomenal resilience through the
coveted pandemic and
leadership and and i think that's
something
that children should learn about
understand about in schools i think it's
also he's a great communicator and one
of the things we seek to teach uh in all
our schools is the importance of
communication
literacy through great speech and
language
and so there's plenty for people to look
up to in that respect and i think the
prime minister will be judged in the
long run uh by his legacy uh the way in
which he's seen uh this country uh
through the pandemic and delivered some
of the strongest group for this country
the way we've invested um that's
something that i i
think i'm very proud to support him
yeah i mean legacy of breaking the law
as you'll know has been fined for um
those lock down parties i mean it's
embarrassing isn't it you said that you
think he he's a great communicator but
it's embarrassing that the school social
media
doesn't think that the prime minister is
a good role model
i think the prime minister has accepted
that there are things for which he's uh
apologized and it's quite right but she
should do that and in that respect as
well that's something that i think it's
important that children understand the
importance of acknowledging when you've
got things uh wrong but i think he's
also someone who has taken the big calls
taking great uh decisions in the long
run and and
and i think that's why uh the party uh
have been behind him when he's had this
vote of confidence earlier in the week
that's why i think he needs to now
continue to show that he's listening for
british people and delivering on their
priorities
and tell us there mr walker about this
announcement today over 14 000 extra
school places um being uh assigned how
is that going to be paid for
uh so this is um
an exciting announcement but we are
delivering not just in the the
mainstream school sector where we are
going to be delivering uh more uh
targeted places in the areas where
they're needed most new school
provisions particularly in the 16 to 19
sector in areas that don't have it in
our
education investment areas that we set
out during the white paper but also
crucially the specialist places which i
know the system has been crying out for
and new specialists and alternative
provision settings in terms of how
that's being paid for the chancellor set
out as a spending review 2.6 billion
pounds um for the specialist education
sector this is one element of how that
money will be spent so
new provision where it's needed and i
know from listening to schools and
listening to teachers in my constituency
there are calls for this up and down the
country and
meeting that need we're also going to be
investing in specialist settings in
mainstream schools and expansion for
existing specialist settings this is one
element of that 2.6 billion package
and alongside that the investment in
mainstream schools targeted to be areas
that need the most is part of the
ongoing investment by the department uh
to deliver new school places in a way
that will help to level up education and
meet our ambitions to drive up literacy
and numeracy and attainment in every
area of the country
and with that in mind mr walker why has
there been an increase in the number of
children who were seeking free school
meals
i think this reflects the
pressures that we've been talking about
and and you know that that is something
that we want to make sure that people
are properly supported we've developed a
system both with free school meals and
with a pupil premium which the
conservative government introduced in
2011 um
that means we support people
according to the challenges they face
and the disadvantage and i think we
should be absolutely right to listen to
the evidence to see if those numbers go
up or down we should make sure that the
funding follows
and that's why we have uh raised the the
largest ever amount of people premium
this year i want to make sure that that
continues to increase to support people
and to make sure that
those challenges that pupils may face in
their daily lives are reflecting the
support that they get in schools and
that's why i i think not only the the
people premium has reached its highest
level this year but we're also doubling
the recovery premium for secondary
schools to make sure that those peoples
who need it most get the catch-up
support that they need
okay robin walker minister for school
standards do you appreciate your time
this morning sir thanks for being with
us thank you